thank you
[Music]
do you guys know about how Queen
Elizabeth died how'd she die no I don't
know how she died I know like right
before she had I know that we were
really good on about getting it on time
that was the first time in 10 years that
we were on time with news guess what
because you you suggested it good yeah
thank you yeah
another 40 pickup I just got my pay
slash it again God damn it you're trying
to move us up and we'll only go down I'm
sorry okay and can edit it and upload it
so shout outs you can no the queen we
also deleted half the footage that's
true that's true so he's able to watch
plus one minus one but we're gonna make
up for it by cutting the cans going like
this
sometimes we don't have footage
um no the Queen's cause of death has
been discovered so apparently
uh it's [ __ ] wild right so so Queen
Elizabeth was actually in the in the
Royal Palace right and she's walking
through one of the corridors and Charles
comes out and goes boo I'm kidding damn
and she slips and falls
she slips and falls and the poor old
lady her body couldn't take her little
her little heart oh that is scary
looking scary yeah you made a very funny
observation about him what was that
observation Mark that his eyes are very
very close together insert picture right
here okay does it doesn't the bush like
George Bush and George was senior look
like Prince Charles kinda if you put
them together it's all inbreeding
families yeah that's the conspiracy 100
that's conspiracy they all look like the
Mad TV kid
they all look exactly like him yeah no
um so after the after the queen I don't
know how you guys got into the cause of
death I was saying after the queen died
how did we get into the cause of death
you you told us about you guys [ __ ]
postulated like oh how did she die I'm
like I don't [ __ ] know I'm like no
you guys know how the queen died I know
I'm like you guys know how the queen
died right
are you gaslighting us right now I feel
like you asked us
oh my goodness no never getting married
um so there was there was word all of a
sudden something started trending on
Twitter and it's called the Kohinoor
diamond
oh you guys know what that is yes so the
Kohinoor Diamond I don't know if I'm
pronouncing it right whatever
um it's an Indian of Indian originally
this is the thing that Tess was talking
about yeah right what do you say that
they like have one of their National
Treasures but they're just not giving it
back yes it's part of the Queen's Crown
right so it yeah it's actually on her
crown so it's a curse
yeah it makes it makes you live 96 years
no so so it's on her crown right that's
[ __ ] up it's it's so it's either this
one or this one up here I believe it's
this one yeah I believe it's the center
one what the [ __ ] she needs to wear that
hat for anyway
we need [ __ ] oceans 14 to come and
then Heist it and give it back to wait
so I missed like the biggest part of
this detail why does the diamond matter
so it was stolen from they well they say
it was stolen the queen says it was fair
and square we took over your land and we
took the diamonds fair and square yeah
and the queen said that a bunch of times
yeah Spoils of War yes I think James got
it for her
uh who did James James got the Diamond
Horse James Earl Jones so who's James
you you know Sweet Baby James the lawyer
oh sweet James it was in documentary
diamonds are forever okay no no one's oh
yeah James Bond yeah the Roger Moore
movie
I forgot okay good well done 007 uh so
here is a replica this is a replica of
it because because obviously it's been
out in circulation for a long time they
weren't able to take picture of it damn
but that's the that's the replica of the
kohen Kohinoor that thing looks like
it's this big it's just zoomed in like a
[ __ ] big boy
um but they're they're saying hey the
queen passed yeah give it back because
because the The Queen's Crown is for the
queen now they're gonna have a king's
crown unless he's changing genders and
saying guess what I'm the queen can't
have it I identify as a queen so he did
not do that he actually came out today
as King Charles the Third I believe he
came out today as king Jarvis well no
because they actually have transitions
they actually have the the coordination
or whatever no they have the right to
come up with their a new name like the
pope almost right it's like your name is
Nick right but then you're like I want
to be [ __ ] you know Francis or
something King Constantine or some [ __ ]
what really so his name is what King
Charles his name is King Charles third
I've been so dope if he did I want to be
king Kanye yeah that'd be so funny my
name was Charles I'd rather be Charlie
sounds friendlier like a [ __ ] though
nah but like it's it's like that's what
he needs right now because Charles is
too threatening because there's been a
King Charles that shit's like too like
dictatory he needs to come out with King
Charlie Charlie yeah
I don't know Bart doesn't like it I like
King Arthur oh that'd be sick yeah we
haven't had a King Arthur in like 2 000
years or some [ __ ] 2 000. so if they
give that [ __ ] back that's a pretty
slippery slope for lots of countries
having to give back lots of [ __ ] yeah
you know what I mean put the crown in
the museum
that's probably what they usually do
then a lot of things are gonna have to
go to a lot of museums exactly so does
that mean if India wages war with like
the UK just take [ __ ] then they could be
like well Finders Keepers on our part
too
yeah so why don't they just do that
because then goodbye other trade
relations once India uh attained their
independence in 1947 the government
actually formally requested for the
diamond to be returned to oh they filed
a refund and the queen of the Queen of
England then the same Elizabeth who just
died when she was younger yeah said that
you guys can go [ __ ] yourself exactly
she sent back the nicest cursive Anew no
yeah because that makes sense to me
because like if you were if you occupy a
country and you take stuff and then once
the occupation's over it's not like you
go hey guys my bad like here's your
stuff it was a war they won the war she
said she said you guys can go pound it
up sideways and break it off that's what
she said yeah because it you know they
could do it like a Trailblazer she
really said she did she said pound it up
sideways and break it off that's that's
like UK slang though yeah yeah because
they could do it they could do it like
Japan and Germany's doing or they're
saying like oh like Jeremy's saying the
Holocaust didn't happen some of the
people some of the historians in Japan
are saying oh no we didn't we didn't
um rape and murder anybody Japanese is
like huh no you crazy and then England
could just do like Prince Charlie could
I mean King Charlie could do that and be
like but no we didn't steal anything
it'd be like the diamond dude we found
it in England when we got here yeah okay
what we say about the nukes of Nagasaki
and Hiroshima right we're like
oh we had to do it guys
there was no way around it man there's
no [ __ ] way we did the math we're
like oh this is no [ __ ] way
that's you know you know why one of the
reasons though that um it's because
before
um so that so they knew that Japanese
soldiers would do like suicide attacks
they would be in these situations where
like half of the soldiers don't even
have ammo anymore and they would just
[ __ ] fight till the death so they're
like
this is going to take a long time to win
especially if we get on their soil so
they're like we gotta do something crazy
let's just kill millions of them but
isn't there an angle to this right we're
Victor really does write the history
yeah so we've all completely accepted
this Narrative of like we had to do it
two million Americans would have died
Garen [ __ ] team granted we don't know
what the weather's gonna be tomorrow but
we know for a fact two main Americans
are gonna die guaranteed and you're
right like the moral winner is always
the winner always the winner yeah yeah
right and then we all tell the story and
pass it down to our kids and their kids
that's true so
um yeah India's basically saying King
Charles needs to acknowledge the black
history of the origins of how they
receive the diamond at the very least
what what country has no black history I
don't understand well it's supposed to
use Korea Korea we we've never won Korea
is without fault butt [ __ ] by everybody
we've never won they've just been like
what the [ __ ] dude can I get a break and
then they come out with K-pop and
everyone's like yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah
stuff with refrigerators and washers and
dryers yeah yeah for sure Even in our in
our well it was a conflict back then now
that I call it the Korean War I don't
know what's changed but when it was the
Korean conflict they wouldn't even let
us be one country they're just like okay
you know what we're gonna divide yeah
they played the Cold War out on you guys
you know what we we did some research
and we're like yeah this won't work
because one country I do too yeah I do
too the best I could do is two yeah we
did the Carolinas we're good that's what
we do The Dakotas I mean it's is it not
going well come on that's the signature
move just turned in two yeah split it up
with Hawaii we made it like [ __ ]
seven dude were you gonna get something
are you okay yeah yeah I'm dehydrated oh
there's a bug that's what it was
he freaked out and it was like whoa hey
bar what's taking thing to the coin or
Diamonds the Carino diet Korean or
diamond I think he likes it I I really
wonder what's gonna happen now with
Western Nations losing their strong
propaganda and control over their public
because it like if if you mention this
even as early as 20 years ago people
would be like shut the [ __ ] up right
but then now people are just smarter and
especially they just they question their
own government and [ __ ] like that
they're gonna be like hey this sounds
kind of ridiculous why do I have to kill
this other person from this nation are
they really threatening me like I feel
like nine after 9 11
everyone got duped and they're like
there wasn't no massive like weapons of
mass destruction like we were in the
Middle East for so [ __ ] long killing
innocent people are they really trying
to kill us dude they raised a generation
of us though with Nightly News Graphics
of like the threat levels orange and
if you live in any of these major cities
the terrorists want to kill you the most
and that's all the major cities so it's
like I remember I remember going to bed
and in San Diego California where I was
when 9 11 happened and it's like and the
Nightly News is like the top cities the
terrorists want to hit with a [ __ ]
[ __ ] a dirty bomb and it's like New
York L.A uh Chicago Philly San Diego and
I'm like that's me dude like [ __ ] hey
and but that works right that propaganda
works on your brain completely and every
time you saw a dude with a turban in the
airplane you're like I'm not racist but
God damn this is kind of scary you know
like everybody got but they've been
doing this like they did that when
during World War II every [ __ ] Asian
War they made some Asian a scapegoat
like whether it's Vietnam Korea or Japan
and then during 9 11 they turned all
these Arabs who were in the United
States into into pariahs yeah they they
even use the FBI they wouldn't trap
innocent people who were just like
talking to people on Facebook or
whatever or on my space or whatever
Messengers and then they would entrap
them with fbias and say yeah you're
guilty guilty guilty we got another
terrorist over here guys and then
everyone in America is just like yay we
got another terrorist down dude Nadeem
was saying how when he traveled after 9
11 he would him and his family would
always be randomly Target randomly yeah
and you know what people would say to
that back then good yeah that's what's
Wild yeah that's what's Wild that's why
I always try to remember and remind
people about manzanar where they had the
Japanese people in the German camps
which is by mammoth super cold you know
and then they lost all their assets they
lost everything so part of me obviously
doesn't want that at all you know
because it's bad but a part of me it'd
be kind of cool because then
everyone's poor everyone's starting from
zero again yeah you know everyone
starting from zero we're kind of
rebooting
to like have a good girl you have to
have a good personality yeah because
everyone's this is how bad Bumble is
right now this is how bad it is does
that does that mean that like with now
that uh Americans are are unoccupying
the Middle East are they going to give
back all the oil
no probably yeah we're definitely
leaving the Middle East that's more oil
to make you can make it even bigger
diamond with that much oil oh [ __ ] I
don't know not don't even worry about it
we're we're back in Syria
[Music]